jean-claude revient ici toutes les trois
semaines il est atteint d'un lymphome
il restera au moins quatre heures
allongé pour une chimiothérapie
le service ne lui est pas étranger que
le fait que le médecin soit là et si
j'étais bon et qu'ils ont passé déjà
habité avec le médecin et avec lui bon
médecin qui étaient là dès demain s'il
va vous étonner
jean-claude garde espoir comme d'autres
ici dans la salle d'attenté
certains sont là depuis trois heures
quand y en a pas d un terme s'est passé
l'enfant d'aujourd'hui tout c'est très
long martin docteur une trentaine de
personnes est accueillie chaque jour
quatre médecins seraient nécessaires
pour faire fonctionner ce service de
manière optimale
il y en avait un il est en congé maladie
depuis deux semaines et la
réorganisation ne fait au fisc de
pansements on a quand même la chance
d'avoir des internes qui ont eu le temps
d'avoir un petit peu les directives de
l'hématologue on a aussi un médecin qui
n'a pas la spécialité mais qui a quand
même une belle expérience en hématologie
et puis on peut quand même dire merci
aussi à l'institut gustave roussy qui
reste en cup et ul communication avec
nous une dizaine de patients a été
réorienté depuis cette nouvelle
organisation des soins effectués à
domicile ou en cabinet de quoi régler
les insuffisances à court terme
un médecin qui s'est engagé en principe
arriver au 1er janvier ce qui marqua
pour les patients le début d'une
stabilisation de leur prise en charge
et puis sur le court terme en fait c'est
un combat qu'on mène chaque semaine la
résignation de semble avoir gagné le
personnel qui malgré un contexte
difficile maintient une attention de
tous les instants